we made it to the end of yellowjacket
season two and we've lost some people
along the way I'm saying it now I think
we'll lose more in episode nine I mean
people are definitely gonna die but I
wouldn't consider officer syracusa a
loss so to be clear I think we'll
probably lose another major character
before all is said and done today I'll
be previewing the season finale talking
specifically about the teaser that
played at the end of episode eight so if
that sounds spoilery then this video
won't be for you you started this
so you better not start making people
feel bad about it now
the teaser opens with this shot from 96
that we've seen in multiple trailers by
this point we finally know the body on
the stick is hobbies and even though the
Converse made this seem fairly certain
it was still really hard to figure out
how they would decide to murder this
quiet young fellow who was mostly just
minding his business since he got back
from his long Hiatus in the wilderness
turns out they didn't really have to
make the decision they just had to not
save him when he went into the lake but
they did make the decision to murder
someone and to let the cards decide who
it would be this was set in motion by
Tai who now that Lottie is laid up had a
vision where she saw the other one first
in a reflection in the window and then
sort of actually in the room behind her
Tai also woke from sleep right before
things got put into motion so that might
be an interesting detail to keep in mind
but the show chose not to show us how
the idea of sacrificing one of their own
was worked out amongst the group we just
skipped ahead to drawing the cards where
Nat is the one who drew the Queen of
Hearts regardless of the details of how
they got there the motivation was
related to lottie's condition of course
they're all starving and feeling the
effects but they're able to use lottie's
imminent demise to justify their next
round of cannibalism from the teaser it
looks like when she wakes up most likely
after being nourished by some hobby stew
she's upset to see what they've done
Misty tells her that she's the one who
started it and that she better not start
making people feel bad about it now
speaking of feeling bad the next shot is
of Travis holding his younger brother's
body Shauna is standing behind him with
a knife in her hand getting ready to
butcher him and there's a lot written on
his face when Travis turns to look at
her remember he saved Nat which is what
set to chase in motion and since he
didn't participate in that he wasn't
there to save hobby when he fell into
the frozen lake this sets up a situation
where he'll likely be at odds with
everyone in the group weirdly I think
even that based on how we've seen him
react to things in the past which means
that since she wasn't actively involved
that he'll probably only be okay with
Lottie in the present day in the sharing
Shack Shauna says we have to do it the
way we used to over a shot of Lottie
with her eyes closed wearing some kind
of golden clothing where she looks
excited like she's getting ready and
she's into it the old way is what we're
seeing play out in the 96 timeline here
with hobby I guess that's what she's
referring to and that response to
shawna's suggestion that the they do
that again by asking have you all
forgotten where that leads but just in
the very next scene we see Lottie
shuffling the cards which tells us what
their answer is
way we used to have you all forgotten
where that leads this brings up some
questions considering that in the past
they let the cards pick Nat but hobby is
the one that died I assume that it won't
always go that way I'm guessing the pit
girl was the one that picked a card in
that round considering she's wearing
Jackie's heart necklace when they chase
her from what adult Lottie says she
believes that the Wilderness wants one
of them the way to appease it is to
sacrifice and seeing them standing
around the fire says that's what they're
getting ready to do they believe it has
to choose which is why she had the
drinks that all look the same but only
one contained a lethal dose of
phenobarbital this prevents van from
revealing she has cancer and offering
herself up or any of the other ones for
that matter who actually gets picked
could go a lot of different ways part of
me thinks Shauna and Misty are the only
ones that feel absolutely safe but even
then there are no guarantees van would
be tragic but the cancer would would
take some of the edge off beyond that
it's hard to imagine taking any one of
these characters off the board so much
so that it's hard to put a theory
together based solely on what's happened
this season it's also entirely possible
that someone unrelated will get mixed up
in it and I think that you'd have to put
Lisa on the top of that list since it
doesn't seem like her story's complete
there is a deadly drinking play that I
think would satisfy lottie's idea of it
choosing if someone were to actually
drink that but it's hard to imagine how
that would play out based on what we see
in this teaser I think if Lisa were to
get involved it would be more likely
that she tries to intervene if she gets
wind of what's going on but even there
maybe it makes more sense if Nat does
something to protect her based on the
relationship they've built Nat did get a
pass when Javi fell in the lake so if
you press me to choose one of the adults
I'd probably have to pick her she was
ready to take her own life at the end of
last season and there was also some
chatter about Juliette Lewis not liking
how the character was so focused on
Travis in the first season but I'm not
really sure if that would have any kind
of effect on how things play out either
way I think we saw in episode 8 that
Javi taking her place is probably one of
the root causes of her troubles in
adulthood so I could see her being more
accepting more inviting of being the one
who gets chosen than the other women I
mentioned that we see them around the
fire and then there are also these shots
with these very cool masks and boy they
hit a lot differently than they did
during Doom coming huh you hear Lottie
telling their victim that they can
submit or that they can run which makes
it sound like The Masks are coming out
after a choice has been made
Walter and Jeff also make an appearance
and based on the heliotrope Walter has
on I'm guessing they're having their
introduction at lottie's compound after
he introduces himself with a big old
grin he asked Jeff if he wants to help
him move this body which of course we
don't see whose body that is Jeff's on
the ground and he looks shocked and
since Walter fired off an email to
syracusa I'd imagine he was setting him
up and that we're probably seeing the
aftermath of their meeting episode 8
went a way to put its hand on the scales
to make it look like he was betraying
Misty but since I don't want to see that
happen I'm going with him trying to
swoop in and save the day there's also a
shot of him hugging what I presume is
Misty with the police lights in the
background that seems to back this up
sentimentality aside this would solve
some problems for the adults that's the
whole reason why they're going through
with this ritual and it would also
provide some satisfaction that the
expense of a character that was crafted
in such a way that you had no choice but
to hate him and root for his demise Cali
also makes a quick appearance but I
can't gather anything from the shot
she's in seems like she's probably just
there with Jeff and they're coming to
look for Shauna there's a shot of Ben
looking mortified which I think is
probably him returning from the cave and
seeing them skinning Javi or otherwise
preparing him for consumption he missed
out on the whole thing so he's bound to
be a little surprised whenever he sees
what's happening when he returns you do
see blood dripping on the snow and then
Shauna crying probably after she
fulfilled her role as the team butcher I
can't imagine that anyone will be
feeling great about what they're about
to do here as soon as I saw the shot of
Travis holding the body I started to
think about whether he might consume his
brother or Not by the end of the teaser
they provided an answer when you see the
heart tossed in a frying pan before
seeing Travis put it into his mouth and
this is about as gross the situations as
I can imagine writing about but all
things considered this is a path for
Travis to avoid starvation that makes
sense it feels like he's honoring his
little brother's spirit and that he'll
be a part of him forever which is all
very Twisted I know but if you put
yourself in the character's shoes and
the situation they're going through
these are the kind of things that
they're looking for to try to make sense
of it the trailer ends with Nat talking
to what is most likely Ben though you
can't tell for sure I'm also not 100
sure whether she says you or we at the
beginning of what she says but the rest
of it is really don't belong in this
place I think it sounds more like you
like she's telling Ben that he ought to
get out of there but I think it makes
more sense if she says we because I feel
like these two would be naturally Drawn
Together based on everything that's
happened in season two as mentioned I
think Travis will be drawn to Lottie
everyone else was actively chasing her
try trying to kill her so that they
could eat her Ben's really the only one
she has left and he has a pretty big
secret now he's been to the cave I'm
sure he was coming back to talk to Javi
about it but that isn't going to happen
when I saw the bones in the cave I was
thinking that that might have been
Crystal but when I went back and looked
at it again they look like they're a lot
smaller maybe from a bird or a smaller
animal so I'm not even really sure what
he found there except for that was the
place hobby was and I'm really curious
to see who his friend was that lives
there I talked about that in my last
video so this is probably a good place
to leave things looking forward to the
finale seeing how they tie this all up
let me know in the comments what your
theories are and how you think things
will play out please like this video If
you enjoyed it please subscribe to my
channel if you haven't already and
thanks for watching I'll talk to you
soon
foreign